hello everyone uh thanks for coming I I
wasn't exactly sure what I ought to talk
about and I also I have to confess I
made this talk in like a little bit of
haste I didn't have time to make the
background of the slides red so uh here
are just some things that were like on
my mind but maybe if you have questions
or we can talk about things it'll be
fine
um
okay so first of all I'll start with
some classical stuff uh
yeah the slides just look like this
anyway uh let's say like Kai one through
Cayenne are like symbols that you're
supposed to assign to the numbers plus
or minus one so formerly chi I squared
equals one and then like you have this
um well linear polynomial where this sum
of CI chi I where the C's are real
constants given to you and you're trying
to optimize it so you want to find opt
of L which is like the maximum value of
this linear polynomial under uh any
assignment Pi that Maps the Chi's to
plus or minus one so I do like to
distinguish between like the the
variables the indeterminants which are
like symbols and like the assignment to
the variables which is pi here
well this problem is easy when it's a
linear polynomial the optimum value is
the sum of the absolute values of the
coefficients children hope I like the
one Norm of C because you should just
set chi I to be the sign of CI
and I know that physicists like to
minimize and computer scientists like to
maximize I guess being computer
scientists I chose to maximize but it's
all the same
um okay so we may want to make it harder
by having pairwise interactions
uh so maybe now we'll look at like a
degree two polynomial that looks like
this it's like the sum of c i j times
chi I times Chi J
and it's nice is for symmetry if you
assume that c i j equals cji and also I
have the Assumption here that I does not
equal J because there's no point in
putting in like a term with I equals J
because we have this rule like chi I
squared is always one so uh you know
this part never varies a part that's
constant so we don't need to worry about
when optimizing
okay so what can we say let's just
understand what we can say about the
optimum of this quantity
well we'll start with some very trivial
bounds so we have an upper bound
again the optimum is at most like the L1
Norm of the coefficients which I'll
continue to denote like this even though
it's like cij because okay this quantity
is always at most uh plus or minus one
so that's a simple upper bound
um
I will lower bound that the optimum was
at least zero it's actually a little bit
non-trivial
um
here's proof If you haven't seen it
before I'll give it very fast so you can
imagine choosing a uniformly random
assignment where you just assign each of
the chi eyes plus or minus one uniformly
at random
and then you can look at the expected
value of this assignment and then you
know by linear of expectation
um the expectation of each term under a
uniformly random assignment will
actually be zero so the expectation of
the whole thing will be zero
and that means of course there has to be
at least one assignment that makes the
this degree two polynomial at least zero
that's nice it's at least zero and uh
you can if you're not satisfied with
this kind of existential argument you
can efficiently de-randomize this but
actually it's better to just say that
like it's fine for your solution concept
to be a probability distribution on
assignments you know with the figure out
of Merit being like the expected value
which it achieves
that's fine
um actually if you tweak this a little
bit I'll call this an exercise uh you
can show something a tiny bit bigger you
can show the optimum is always at least
one over n the number of variables times
this L1 Norm of the coefficients
it's okay like given age you know it's
somewhere between like the L1 norm and
one over n times L1 norm and that's a
pretty wide Gap if n is big but we can
try to narrow it down
okay so this is lower bound and it's an
upper bound
um
okay well uh these are I'm talking about
you don't help to
uh keep this optimal exactly in
polynomial time because it's it can be
hard
and uh it's a well-known reduction from
the max cut problem on a graph which is
an NP hard problem
and just to State it uh briefly
so I'll call it an exercise
if you take the graph and let a be the
adjacency Matrix of the graph and then
you basically let the cijs be like the
negative of the adjacency Matrix so like
all the
clijs are are minus one if there's an
edge between I and J
and it's not hard to check that the
maximum cut in the graph the maximum
number of edges that you can cut by the
best partition into two parts
is basically the optimum of the
resulting degree to polynomial it's like
one quarter times the optimum plus one
quarter times the sum of the absolute
values of the coefficients anyway like
this is a number that you certainly know
you're staring at the graphs you know
this quantity so you know optimizing uh
this H that you get from the graph is
the same as optimizing this so if you
can't hope to compute this exactly you
can't help to compute this exactly
foreign
okay
so let's go back to bounds now that we
like have this like sad feature that you
know we cannot compute it exactly so
here's a different upper bound that's
also easy to compute in polynomial time
uh it's the maximum eigenvalue of the
Matrix you get from putting these
coefficients into a matrix
uh times n
and we can compute the maximum
eigenvalue efficiently so that's a nice
upper bound
and let's see why this is true
um if you have any assignment pi to
these n cause and you like stack pi and
just like a vector of plus or minus ones
like this
and then you do this like quadratic form
like Pi transpose C pi
um it's easy to check that that equals
the value of the assignment Pi on H
but then like you know from linear
algebra this quantity is always at most
the maximum eigenvalue of c times like
the product the length of these two
vectors so like the two Norm squared of
Pi
but Pi is a vector that has all plus or
minus one so it's two Norms squared is n
so that establishes that bound
okay so now we have this two different
upper bounds
and actually either of these upper
bounds might be better than the other
one
so I'll give some example here's a
trivial example I'm not sure this is
their whole uh polynomial just Chi one
Chi 2 but imagine they're like n
variables we're just choosing not to use
them like all the associated
coefficients are zero
then the sum of the absolute values of
the coefficients is one that's upper
bound one and that's actually also the
optimum one
but like Lambda Max of this Matrix is I
think half if I calculated it right and
so like upper Bound 2 is like n over 2
which is much worse
um on the other hand here's a different
example that's like uh I don't know
physics motivated from physics it's a
case where it's the instance where you
choose all the cijs it to be independent
gaussians it's called the shankton
Kirkpatrick model
um so if you you know choose them at
random and then fix them and study the
optimization uh you know the maximum
value of this
well the upper bound one the sum of the
absolute values of the coefficients
there's basically like N squared uh
terms and the absolute value of a
gaussian and expectation is some
explicit number so uh this first bound
is proportional to N squared with high
probability
but then it's also a famous theorem if
you have like a matrix full of gaussians
the largest eigenvalue is like 2 root n
with high probability so then we
multiply that by n and you get something
that's proportional to n to 1.5
and that's much smaller
so this is an example where like upper
bound two is like smaller than upper
bound one
and
incidentally they know that like the the
optimum is it's smaller than this by a
constant Factor but it's proportional to
this
okay so
um that's a bit funny to have two
different upper Bounds at one sometimes
better than the other
uh can we get like a common
generalization of rounds one and two so
like some easy to compute quantity which
is an upper bound on the optimum but
always at least as good as up around one
and upper bound two
any suggestion
all right
so just sitting all here in silence
I know you know I know some of you know
yes thank you yes
uh yeah there's this STP bound so let's
uh talk about that
so the optimum value of H is like the
maximum you know of this assignment to H
you can get by plugging in plus or minus
ones
um but you know if you also like allow
your solution concept to be like a
probability distribution over
assignments
um and you can say it's the maximum
overall probability distribution on
assignments of you know how much that
assignment gets an expectation
and even if there's like one optimal
assignment you can have the probability
distribution that puts 100 of its
probability on that assignment so this
is an equally valid way to express the
optimum
okay so now if you imagine having a
probability distribution p on
assignments pi
you can make a matrix that encodes uh I
don't know how correlated the
assignments to each pair of variables
Chi and Kai J is
so let's make this Matrix M it's n by n
is IJ entry
is the expected value under the randomly
chosen assignment PI from P of the
assignment to chi chi J
and we can make some observations about
this quantity
uh let's first observe this one like the
diagonal entries Mii are always
um
one because chi I squared is like 1 by
definition
um and it's easy to see kind of similar
to the calculation with the matrices on
the last page that like this quantity
we're interested in the expected value
of the assignment
is some function of this Matrix of
moments and the input C's it's not
usually just trace of M times C
so everything you need to know about the
objective value is encoded in this m and
finally there's this further observation
that for this Matrix m
just let A1 through a n be any real
numbers and look at this quantity
well for a reason similar to what we saw
in the previous slide and by the
definition of am this expression equals
the expected value when pi is drawn from
this distribution of Pi what pi gives to
the square of this linear form sine of
sum of a i chi I
and okay the square of a number is not
negative so this whole expression has to
be non-negative
but then if you just forget that
calculation and see that it tells you
that for any Vector a like a transpose M
A is not negative that's the definition
of m being a positive semi-definite
Matrix
so this Matrix M has like a
several properties here
and
um
so if you just forget the fact that like
maybe M arises from an assignment and
just remember like these facts about it
and optimize over M's that satisfy these
facts then you're relaxing the problem
so you might get like a bigger value but
that's what we do when we study this sdp
which is the maximum over all PSD
matrices and with ones on the diagonal
of the trace of M times the input
numbers C
and the value of this optimization
problem we'll call SOS
2 of H for reasons that I guess I won't
explain but they'll will come up later
I'm the day I'm sure
and this is an example of a
semi-definite program and it's known
that like you can solve them in
polynomial time so this optimal value is
easy to compute
so it's an easy to compute upper bound
on the optimum
and moreover I'll guess I'll call this
an exercise for you
um you can show that this this Optimum
is always less than or equal to Upper
bound one
and it's also also always at most upper
bound too so it's like a it's at least
as good as all the previous upper bounds
any questions right now
okay
uh great so uh
when you make a set so as relaxation is
STP relaxation like the inherent nature
of it is like it's an easy to compute
number which is an upper bound on your
answer it's like a certificate
that the optimum value of for this ah is
at most the number that spits out
and that's good to have like a certified
upper bound on the optimum of H so
uh you might also want like a certified
lower bound so a certified lower bound
is like you know something you can be
sure tells you is a lower bound an
Optimum
and more or less the way you would ever
get such a thing is to like somehow
exhibit like a pretty good assignment
pie for every pie that you exhibit you
compute what value it gives to this
expression h
and that gives you a lower balance
certificate
now of course once you do that you would
like to compare like you would like to
understand how good is this like is it
close to the optimum or what so ideally
you would like to compare like the value
Pi achieves to the Ops
but you know there's this like
philosophical issue that like up is like
an NP hard to compute quantity so like
probably like any math proof you write
can somehow like not really access what
opt is like you can somehow only access
this is a heuristic guide but like
quantities which are computable in
polynomial time so somehow we therefore
usually end up comparing you know how
much a
value of pi gets not to the Ops we don't
know what it is but to like this even
larger number like our best uh you know
known upper bound on opt
um which in this case well a good thing
to compared to in this case is this SOS
or sdp value
and um
because of that we often see this
concept of like a rounding algorithm
which says
uh you know take the optimum of this
this uh optimization problem you can
figure it out and you can figure out M
that achieves some value and rounding
refers to the concept of trying to take
this m which achieves the optimum for
this STP uh and converting it into like
a legitimate assignment Pi that achieves
an amount that is you know gets on age
an amount that's at least some I don't
know fraction let's say of what m is
getting in this program so
um and that of course is at least the
same fraction of the optimum
that's like a paradigm that's often
going on
okay so uh in this context let me
highlight a key result like this due to
namorovski Roos and tarlaki from 1999.
and they did exactly this they came up
with a an efficient rounding algorithm
that takes this optimal STP solution M
and converts it into an actual plus or
minus one in assignment Pi uh which is
real good I mean pretty good it always
gives you a an assignment that's at
least one of our log n fraction of this
upper bound so at least one over login
fraction of Ops
and that's pretty good like you know log
in and want to login is not so bad I
mean it's much better than like the
algorithm implicit in this thing which
gives you like a one over n fraction of
your upper bound so like whatever login
is it's not bad
um this is like an extension of the
gomens Williamson rounding if you've
heard of that
and so this is actually reasonably
satisfactory
um so even though it's MP hard you know
this is decent
um actually there was an improvement to
this
um suggested by five and langberg in
2001 and then analyzed by Char car and
worth in 2004 a little bit complicated
to States let me go through it
um it's the rounding algorithm that
takes this STP solution M and converts
it into a genuine assignment pi
and it's parameterized by a t that U the
algorithm's user get to choose
and it produces an assignment whose
quality is at least this it's a lot of
symbols it's basically whatever key you
choose you get an assignment that this
value is a one over t fraction of the
optimal SOS value
except there's an error that looks good
you're like I will choose T to be one
but there's an error that
um could be as large as this so the
error gets smaller the bigger T is and
it's like multiplied against this naive
upper bound the absolute value of the
some of the absolute value of the
coefficients
so
um let's say you solve your
semi-definite program and you get this
number SOS 2 of H was an upper bound on
the true Optimum and you're like hey
it's it's actually reasonably large
compared to this super naive upper bound
uh the some of the
coefficients so let's say it's at least
some Epsilon times the sum of the
coefficients
um
great then you said to yourself okay
like I know this term is at least
Epsilon times uh one Norm of C
so if I were to do this chart car worth
rounding I would get a solution with
this amount
and then this amount I can just like
optimize myself you should optimize it
by choosing the best T and the best T is
any quick witted people out there
the best T is proportional to
log one over Epsilon yeah so if you then
select T to be log one over Epsilon
uh then you get this this this will
become this will be like Epsilon over
log Epsilon and this will become like
negligible if you make this constant
here large enough
which maybe I should have written
and so the uh quality I mean the value
of the H you get out of this algorithm
is at least uh Epsilon over log one over
Epsilon times this bound
so if you know your upper bound was
Epsilon you get an assignment that's
like Epsilon over log one over Epsilon
and that's pretty good and as I'll say
in the next slide that's like actually
even better than
or at least as good as this
but you know that's good and it's you
know that's not as point one then like
this is just some other constant and you
get like a
a slightly smaller constant than 0.1
um so it's kind of like it's like an
approximation factor of one over log one
over Epsilon it's kind of funny because
the approximation Factor if you will
depends on what the actual you know
value Epsilon is but as I mentioned it's
always better than this one because this
Epsilon uh is a never worse than one
over n because of this thing op is
always at least one over n times this L1
Norm so SOS is always at least one over
n times the cell one Norm so this
Epsilon is never worse than one over n
which means this factor is never worse
than log n so it's it's at least as good
as this one
but that means we can just forget about
this one
um yeah and this is this is quite nice
uh
uh actually okay now that we have this
we can ask the related question is like
what if you saw the STP and you see that
the upper bound on the solution is
actually uh not just like a decent
fraction of this naive upper bound but
it's actually really close to the
um naive upper bound which is so it's
like one minus Delta times uh the naive
upper bound
um then the Goldman's Williamson
algorithm which you possibly heard about
a rounding algorithm uh can convert this
into a genuine assignment that's also
like really close to the naive upper
bound but it's like 1 minus square root
Delta times the naive upper bound that's
still pretty good
goes from like uh
99 to 90 or something like that
um
uh and while we hear a related fact uh
uh from Umesh and others
um
says that if you don't like yeah why is
it good to be close to life up about I
mean I mean the knife upper bond is the
one you get with any assignment right so
it seems that you hungry again
oh no well
um the naive upper bound uh uh it may be
that your instance like doesn't have an
assignment that gets anywhere close to
this like if you remember the sharington
Kirkpatrick example like there this
naive upper bound was like N squared but
the actual Optimum is like n to the 1.5
so that would just be a setting where
like I mean this uh is not the case
but if you happen to be in a setting
where like you can actually kind of
it's very close to the situation where
you get like sort of all the terms
perfectly right like you got all the
arrange for all the signs to be the same
as the C's
um if you happen to like you know
discover that you're in that setting
then uh you can actually find an
assignment by virtue of this you can
actually find an assignment that's like
sort of
almost equal to the
uh upper bound now you've upper bound
but it's a particular case like I mean
this is basically it's not always
applicable
yeah I was going to say if you don't
like
um like the square root here like an
alternative which is also pretty good is
um
well you need you need the triangle
inequality if you know what that means
but if there's a generalization of this
SOS 2 thing to sos4 and if it's uh
sufficiently large or sufficiently near
the naive upper bound then you can find
an assignment that's also in a different
way close to the naive upper bound is
one minus
root log Delta root log n times Delta
um
yeah
so I'll just remember the first one
and by the way uh you might hope to I
don't know make this better than Epsilon
over log one over Epsilon or you might
hope to make this better than root Delta
but we know that actually doing this is
uh it's probably hard it's Unique games
hard
up to the constants and this one is sort
of at least I feel like morally unique
games complete like trying to get like
one minus Delta to the point
five one here uh it's kind of the same
as the unique games conjecture
um
I think
yeah I just want to say that um
these results are pretty good like
degree two is like a case where you can
actually do some interesting stuff one
second and
um you know things are much much harder
as soon as you go to like degree three
you can encode three side and so forth
so to agree two it's a nice case to
study yeah on it there is similar story
when you're really close
uh I don't uh no I don't know of one
does anybody know of one
uh I guess it's kind of like maybe I
don't sit on tier uh it's kind of like
uh this is like you know
you feel uh
uh that perhaps like there's like a
Boolean Vector that's like almost in the
eigen spaces that are achieving the
highest eigenvector so maybe you feel
like oh I could just combine these
eigenvectors to get like a Boolean
vector's inequalities
I think it kind of resembles well
I don't know
maybe do you have anything to say I'm
sorry I'm really putting you on the spot
um
okay yeah I I don't know okay let's put
a pin on it and that's gonna be one of
the things we discussed uh afterwards
good question
it's cool stuff so now I'll start
talking about Quantum stuff is there a
clock in here yeah okay
uh I might not get through all the
quantum stuff but that's okay we're just
here to chat
so I guess the vibe in Quantum stuff is
that your things are now matrices
instead of numbers so let's imagine a
similar problem where Chi 1 to Cayenne
are not to be assigned Square matrices
I'll explain what I mean here a bit more
but we're also because they're matrices
and they're going to have complex
numbers well it's not a big deal but
we'll also introduce the symbol chi I
star and like whatever Matrix apply
assigns to chi I it ought to assign the
dagger of that to Kai I star and we'll
also introduce the symbol one which is
supposed to always be assigned the
identity Matrix of whatever Dimension
your assignment Pi is using
and uh we're gonna insist that like high
I star formally equals Kai I so look
that basically means you're supposed to
be assigning hermitian matrices to the
symbols
and like before you know when the chi I
squared equals one uh we're going to
continue to require that you don't have
to but let's continue to require that
which you know means you're assigning uh
reflection matrices to the the symbols
now
and yeah I don't know how much I'm going
to say how like since it will make so
like please ask questions if you're if I
start to be confusing
so uh before we get to optimizing like
polynomial expressions in these symbols
um we're gonna actually insist on more
things let's talk about insisting on
certain commutation or anti-commutation
relations and I'll bring this a bit down
to earth in a moment
but
here's an example and like this is
related to some paper I wrote and I'm
not supposed to talk about my own work
but like I think it's like a helpful
setting to think about so imagine I just
has like another feature of the
optimization problem I insist that you
assign to these symbols matrices that
pairwise anti-commute
and there do exist matrices like a bunch
of matrices that all pairwise
anti-commute so this is not like a
vacuous or impossible task
um
okay so let's think about this a bit
so let's say we'll start degree one so
like you're given this formal polynomial
expression the C's are real numbers
and uh we're even trying to optimize
because you know you're supposed to
assign um Pi is supposed to assign these
uh symbols to matrices that are like I
don't know uh reflection matrices that
anti-commute
um what are you trying to do you're
trying to maximize the um
uh uh maximum eigenvalue of the
resulting Matrix assignment
okay you're trying to maximize the
maximum eigenvalue or you know the
minimum eigenvalue if you're a physicist
over all the assignments of Pi's to
matrices and your choice of Dimension
that's up to you that satisfy the
requirements
um this problem is actually uh the
linear case is actually easy because a
funny thing happens uh if you just take
this expression formally and like Square
it or like hermitian Square it like
l-star times L doesn't really matter in
this case if you just expand it out like
formally like okay you get like Ci
squared times chi I squared Chi Squared
is the identity so you get sum of uh c i
squared times the identity and then in
the cross terms you'll get like C1 C2
times Chi 1 Chi 2 but you'll also get C1
C2 times
kai2 Chi 1
well they anti-commute it so those terms
cancel
so it's a funny situation if you just
formally expand the square of this like
you get like a number
or the number times the symbol one
um which is the the squared two Norm of
the coefficients
and therefore actually any assignment
that satisfies all the requirements just
must map the square of this uh resulting
Matrix to like this number times the
identity Matrix so it's it's largest
eigenvalue will be
this quantity
okay so here like you don't even have
his choices Optimizer no matter what you
do the uh the value you get will be this
uh two Norm of the coefficients
okay great that was an easy case
why you might study the situation I'll
say a little bit about shortly
okay
uh so naturally like okay let's let's
make it harder and go back to degree two
again
um so here's what I've written for the
degree 2 case now there's something
funny here
um you see I stuck in this factor of I
literally meaning the square root of
minus one here
why do I do that well
um
Kai J Kai k is like not self-adjoint if
you star this you want that if you like
Star this you get the same expression
back
um basically because you want it to be
the case that like any you know Matrix
assignment to this thing gives you a
self-adjoint matrix because then it has
real eigenvalues and it's sensible to
ask about what is the largest of these
eigenvalues
these are real yeah I didn't write that
but these are real
I mean you don't yeah
let's just say sees a real keep it
simple
and uh uh also this is a very minor
comment but now if you're stacking these
C's into a matrix because of this
anti-commuting the natural uh way to do
it will make an anti-symmetric Matrix
it's not a big deal
um yeah so this is Alpha joint because
if you like Star this you get a minus
sign here because of the I but then when
you like undo the swap due to
anti-commutivity it gets back to this
just like this is a natural degree two
polynomial in these symbols that you
would try to optimize
and uh maybe here's the reason you might
try to optimize this I'm not I'm sure
like 100 people in this room know better
than me what's going on but I guess like
such hamiltonians can be used to model
like
um the situation where you have n over
two fermions with like one wise
interactions and you might be like I was
like wait a minute it's like doesn't
isn't this pairwise interactions but I
guess like fermions have like our
Associated like one fermion is
associated with one creation and one
Annihilation operator and uh yada yada
like this somehow models one wise
interactions
four you might be interested in physics
reasons for optimizing this
although it's not really the way they
think about it but it's equivalent and
it's because
so I phrase this to like match the
classical stuff I phrase this with about
being finding like the best Matrix
assignment to like make the the
resulting Matrix when you substitute
into this H has a large eigenvalue as
possible but actually that's kind of
misleading because
um once you have like these
anti-commuting constraints there's
basically like a unique assignment pi
it gives you an exponentially large
Matrix and the exponent actually large
dimension in order to find these
matrices that paralyze anti-commute but
basically there's only one
um in some sense like up to you know
unitarily conjugating all the matrices
simultaneously which doesn't change the
maximum eigenvalue and also up to like
stacking them in a direct sum fashion
which also doesn't change the maximum
eigenvalue
so in some sense like there's in this
problem actually there's no like search
aspect to it in a certain sense like
there's a but there's like it's like uh
you have to understand an exponentially
large Matrix represented in this
implicit way
yeah
it's called exactly solvable
that'll be on a slide coming up yep
okay and actually this one only I have
only one like message I'm trying to get
across actually in this talk which is
the vibe and the vibe is
don't even worry about like what are
what are these matrices I could tell you
these matrices you can write down a
formula that like all like n matrices a
pairwise anti-commute don't even worry
about it the vibe is never worry about
the matrices only think about the
relations like the formal algebraic
relations of the symbols that's the
that's the vibe
[Music]
um
so how can you do that let me try to
understand how you can do that so okay I
told you you're trying to I mean let's
think about it like in a previous way
you're like you're trying to find uh the
largest a pie or maybe it's this unique
Matrix assignment pi
and you're trying to find the understand
the largest eigenvalue of it well the
largest eigenvalue of a matrix probably
or possibly you know
um another way to express it is like
it's the maximum possible value of trace
of row times that Matrix over all
density matrices rho
matrices that are PSD with Trace one
it's just a little linear algebra fact
um
now cool thing about you know complex
Square matrices is a matrix
an actual Matrix is PSD if and only if
it's a square like the square hermitian
square of another Matrix if only if it's
like you know the hermitian square of
some other Matrix l so like this is like
a perfect SOS scenario you're like
positive if and only if you're a square
so that's nice
so now
uh okay here's like a the trickier part
let this is this is varro right let
varro be a formal polynomial like this
one in the symbols Chi 1 through Cayenne
and I'm going to call such a formal
polynomial in these symbols a state
if two things happen first of all it's
the hermitian square of some formal
polynomial
um
and its Trace is one but what is a trace
of a polynomial from a polynomial it
just means the constant term
a coefficient of like the symbol one
okay so in some ways this is like you
can I'm kind of aligning some details
here but this is like you can think
about
States or density matrices back in the
world of like polynomials
oh yeah
and so
um it turns out I mean you if I think
about this for a moment you see that you
can equivalently Define the optimum of
this formal polynomial
only in the language of like formal
polynomials and forget matrices it's the
maximum of the trace of rho times H
that's what you get when you multiply
these two formal polynomials together
and Trace is just like please tell me
the constant term where the Max's
overall States rho and a state remember
a row is a state it fits like the square
of something and it's its constant
coefficient is one
I'll give an example sort of here
but like what's nice about it is
connects to the messages now everything
is happening in the algebra formal
polynomials there's no matrices anymore
and like
I encourage you to sometimes think about
your problem in this way if you can
um
so okay yeah so
this one I've been talking for a while
about this running example where like oh
I put it's like a side condition all the
symbols have to anti-commutes but uh
you're probably like I don't normally
study that situation like I'm into like
um
I don't know like uh well here's another
different example let's say I say like
oh no no all the symbols commute
that's my new rule all the stimulus
commute
but the same problem so in principle
you're like you're searching for
assignment of matrices to these symbols
where all the matrices pairwise commute
and you're trying to make the assignment
value for age have the largest
eigenvalue possible
and in that situation you'll probably
start thinking these thoughts like all
these matrices commute so they're like
simultaneously diagonalizable so I may
as well just do that that's going to
change the eigenvalues
um and as you'll see it actually just
turns into like the classical problem
from the first half of the talk
um but you can also see this at the
level of polynomials we can still say
like all right
persistent bug this is our definition of
the Ops
and again in this world where they all
commute they're somehow like a unique
maximal assignment Pi of these symbols
to matrices
um that encompasses all the sort of
distinct possibilities it's the one
again don't be too excited about the
matrices but it's the one that looks
like a poly string with like a z in the
jth position
these are matrices that all pairwise
commute n of them
and
um yeah because of this it follows that
like
uh the classical problem we started in
the first half of the talk is like
equivalent to this like optimization
problem in the land of polynomials where
you just don't think even think about
assignments too much or like matrices
just you think that the symbols commute
and square to one the identity
so yeah
and um here's a fact like if you want to
connect the sort of you know assignments
a plus or minus one values to like
States and so forth for any like string
of plus or minus ones it might be the
assignment values
this varro
which is a formal polynomial is a state
if you multiply all this out the
constant term will be one
and it doesn't look like it's a perfect
square but actually it is a perfect
square because like if you think about
this from a moment if you like Square
this Factor
and like use that chi I squared as one
and that this cause commute well you
don't need that yet you'll get that like
the square of this is basically itself
up to a factor of two so this is a
square and this is a square and this is
a square and they all commute so like
this whole thing is a square
follow but um
yeah and the the just to connect it to
this funny way of thinking about it the
the trace of this state times the
hamiltonian if you like multiply this
all out and keep the constant term it's
just the value of the classical
assignment of like these Chi's getting
these plus or minus one values
um
yeah
and also by the way like under this
unique maximal assignment of these like
Paulie
um strings this state is a matrix and
what Matrix is it it's just a pure
product state of KET zeros and Cat ones
foreign
okay so back to the uh anti the the
setting where let me go back now to the
setting where all the variables pairwise
anti-commute
and one thing I want to say is like this
is a very nice the reason I like
actually kind of harp on this example is
it kind of simulates all the other
examples that you might study
so what do I mean by this
so let's let's say if you're in the
world where all your symbols
anti-commute
you can use this to simulate the world
where all the symbols commute and
therefore you can use it to simulate the
classical problems we discussed in the
first half of the talk
so why well take your n symbols that are
supposed to pairwise anti-commute and if
you just pair them up into pairs you
have to do the stupid thing of
multiplying by I to make it
self-adjoint
these you know n over too many little
degree two expressions are like symbols
that are self-adjoint and they Square to
one and they pairwise commute
so if you can think of those like new
symbols like how the right algebraic
properties like pairwise commute so like
um you can use these little symbols to
like set up like a classical problem
right so if you're interested in seeing
you know the classical problem of like
optimizing some of CI times
you know one variable you just do like
sum of CI times you know this plus this
plus this
now when you do that actually you know
you would take a degree one classical
problem it would become like a degree
two problem in this like simulation
world so you might think like oh I made
the problem more complicated but
hang on maybe you didn't make it so much
more complicated
General you can simulate the degree K
commuting classical problem in the
degree 2K anti-commuting setting
and it also simulates if you're willing
to like k-local hamiltonians
um
which I think many people are same story
it's uh you can also simulate it K local
with degree 2K here as well
and why is that well here's the trick
um let's say you have a k local
hamiltonian problem with uh n uh qubits
well you're like oh I'll take 3n
anti-commuting symbols and like here
instead of calling them Chi 1 through
Chi 3n I'm going to call them Alpha One
beta1 Gamma One Alpha two beta 2 gamma
two but like think about you're like oh
all all three any of these variables
pairwise anti-commute
foreign
but now in a similar way you're like oh
let's make some little degree two
monomials out of these guys let's look
at Alpha J times beta J and put the
stupid I in and like also Alpha J times
gamma J and also beta J times gamma J
these little three degree two
polynomials
exactly satisfy the poly relations like
what are the public relations this one
times this one is negative of this one
for example it's like it's a one second
exercise using the fact that everything
anti-commutes and moreover like you know
you know Alpha One beta 1 commutes with
like Alpha 10 beta 10 like the different
groups pairwise commute
and so again if you're in this like Vibe
where like the only thing that really
matters is the you know the algebraic
relations between these symbols and you
forget about matrices and everything
then yeah you see that
um okay you can simulate you know like K
local polyhonotonians is a special case
of like optimization in this fully
anti-commuting world if you're willing
to increase the degree by a factor of
two
and so for example like I don't know if
this is like a good idea but like if
you're into like Quantum Max Cuts it's
the same as like optimizing a special
kind of degree for hamiltonian in this
setting
where like every term kind of looks like
it's like a positive linear combination
of terms that have this special form
um okay
so uh
so because of that like okay this is
like a pretty general setting so let's
think about it for a moment we'll get
back to the the question from earlier
let's think about the degree 2 case of
optimization in this world where all
your symbols anti-commute which can
simulate I don't know one local
hamiltonians for example
so this is at least as hard as like you
know a degree one classical or like
local one uh hamiltonians but those are
easy problems
this is at least as hard as those
but I was just pointed out this problem
is also easy you're like oh wait it's a
degree two but it's easy that's
interesting is it but it's true
um so I I won't prove it but it's like
not very hard to show that
um given in a degree to
expression these symbols the optimum is
just the maximum eigenvalue of the
Matrix of C's
well times I again so you can just
compute that and moreover it's easy to
uh describe and write down a
representation of the optimizing state
the actual set of states that like
optimize degree two polynomials like
this has a horrible name well in my
opinion I'm sorry to whoever invented it
they're called gaussian States but I
don't like this name
and actually don't really worry about
this formula too much but like calcium
States is a class of States but like
which are like now
um uh expressions like formal
Expressions that look like this in terms
of the the Kai's
and they have like a nice simple format
you can write down on a piece of paper
they're actually like you know full like
end degree n Expressions but you could
still write them down and like given any
hamiltonian it's easy to evaluate like
what is the value you get of that
hamiltonian under this gaussian state
it's a formula and like the state of all
states that are like this are exactly
all the possible optimizers of degree
two
hamiltonians
is there a question
so it's a nice class of states
um it's exactly the States you need to
solve degree two
and um if you are playing this game of
saying like oh I'm interested in like
you know spin systems local poly
hamiltonians but I'll do this trick of
like encoding them with like products of
two uh
fully anti-commuting symbols
and under this trick the class of
product States and you're back in your
like basic you know qubit spin world is
like a subset of the gaussian states
so that's also nice that kind of
contained product stays in this sense
so similarly we can go up to degree four
polynomials in these fully
anti-commuting variables and it's a
natural thing to do because from what we
said degree 4 and this anti-commuting
case like can simulate you know degree
two classical KS or degree two uh looks
like local hamiltonian case
and we we kind of really love this case
in computer science these cases because
like okay it doesn't be hard but like
there's cool stuff to do you got scps
you got approximation algorithms
sometimes you actually get a good
approximation algorithms so it's like a
fun setting it's not like impossibly
hard like the three-stop world and so
forth
so this is at least as hard as degree
four in this case is at least as hard as
degree two and like these more familiar
cases but uh has the same Spirit like it
turns out that like oh sometimes the
degree 4 case is also like decently and
proximable and like you get some cool
results with STP routing and stuff
and um
particularly I'm not that familiar with
this word onsats but like when you use
like gaussian States as onsats like
there's many many different kinds of
like States but like
you know gaussian States is a simple
class of states that you can try as like
your optimizers
um yeah I'm not sure how much time I
have to go through all this but let me
say a few more things so
um yeah so I hope that motivates you to
think a little bit about this case
degree 4 optimization and you have a
similar situation
um one naive upper bound is the sum of
the absolute values of the coefficients
and another upper bound this one's not
so easy to prove but like another upper
bound is n times the sum well the two
Norm of the coefficients
and again there's this feature that
um sometimes either of these could be
better than the other but there's a
common generalization of both of them
which is like the degree eight SOS value
of this expression which I won't Define
but maybe we'll hear about later today
and it's also computable and polynomial
time with the semi-definite program
and uh maybe similar to the flavor of
like completely General like two local
hamiltonians it's actually kind of hard
so like one thing you might do and this
was suggested by
um Ravi gossip uh Karen again Tema this
is a great paper if you haven't studied
before
um they said well it's kind of a hard
problem but maybe we should just
consider the simple problem of trying to
like optimize this not over all states
but over the gaussians days because we
can understand gaussian States pretty
well they have an explicit formula you
can explicitly evaluate how well they're
doing on like
I'll give it a polynomial so you can
Define this quantity which will of
course always be less than or equal to
the true Optimum
you know you could it's reasonable to
decide to be interested in this quantity
and uh what's also nice is you can write
down a semi-definite program that's a
relaxation of this so it's kind of weird
here's the optimum then here's the
optimum Over gaussian States but then
like here's a relaxation of the optimum
or gaussian States so these things are a
little bit incomparable
but this is a cortex size sdp relaxation
of of this quantity
just natural to think about
and uh one uh this is sort of a a simple
thing that they showed
so it's not great but um
the first thing you might ask is like
how far could this be from the true
Optimum when you like optimize only over
this philosophy of gaussian States like
is that terrible or is it like kind of
good they show that like it's not
terrible so like the optimum Over
gaussian States is at least
well one over n fraction of
uh
um the optimum the true Optimum sorry
the STP relaxation value is at least one
over n fraction of the true Optimum
and as I'll say on the next slide
there's a rounding algorithm that shows
that the gaussian optimum is pretty
close log n factor to the SCP Optimum if
you put these together you get that like
the auto and gaussian value is at least
one over n log n times the true optimal
value
not amazing because like these differ by
a factor of like n log n but it's not
nothing
um
and then actually conjecture that
perhaps like the optimum gaussian value
is at least a
a constant fraction of the optimum value
but it turns out to be not true it turns
out actually the optimizing over
gaussian state is going to be like quite
bad compared to ultimately over
everything in general
for example uh in the case where all
these cijks are like IID gaussians it's
called the syk model the true Optimum is
like n to the 2.5 but
um the best gaussian state only gets
like N squared so they can differ by at
least a square root n Factor
so that's not great at least for some
kinds of hamiltonians it's not great but
maybe for other kinds of hamiltonians
maybe simpler ones like you know this
gaussian state is a reasonable thing to
study
yeah
it seems like SOS 4 is
it how does it compare like it means
yeah not well understood great question
like how what what can you say about SOS
bounds for
this problem
so it's not known if it is
oh uh it's probably
it might be the case that like sometimes
this is not as good as this bound
but maybe you should just always I don't
know maybe this is the natural
I don't know eight is like two times
four so it's like reasonable to give
like three even the only reason like it
goes to degree eight here is because
like you'd like SOS to be able to talk
about the square of this polynomial
that's that's it
um
so I'm almost done here but I do really
want to mention this paper so
um
if you remember way back for like
classical degree 2 optimization there's
like this natural sdp and then this
namorowski terlocky paper gave us
natural rounding algorithm that was
quite good
so it's kind of I don't know Anthony
manchan so in 2009 gave like a
non-commutative generalization of this
surrounding algorithm
nothing to do with Quantum he's like
straight up like an optimization person
but he was motivated to study this
it's like a little known paper
and this paper of Robbie gossa uh
Carnegie and Tema showed that he's
rounding algorithm
um
is real good for the gaussian setting
the gaussian setting so like whatever
the STP relaxation for the gaussian
optimization problem is like this
rounding gives you something that's at
least one over log n is good
and uh uh you can similarly generalize
this in the the style of this Chara car
worth paper so that like if this
SCP relaxation is close to this upper
bound like it's like an Epsilon fraction
of this upper bound
you get an actual gaussian State that's
like Epsilon over log one for Epsilon
so it's like a good approximation factor
for this sub problem of like not full-on
optimization of this but like
optimization over this nice onsets of
gaussian states
okay I think this is pretty much my last
slide
um so I just I don't know wrote some
open questions that occurred to me in
this setting so um
this result is about if you're like a
constant fraction of this upper bound
number one but
um what about like if you're a constant
fraction of this upper bound which I
think
is uh more relevant for things like a
Quantum Max Cod or two local
hamiltonians they're like you're usually
comparing yourself or you feel like
you're comparing yourself against like
the sum of the absolute value of the
coefficients like the number of edges in
the graph basically and
um
don't know any results about this you
could also ask the analogous high-end
question like what if the STP relaxation
for gaussian states is like really close
to this upper bound can you get Commons
Williamson type thing don't know
anything about ug hardness
um another interesting thing is like
um the hamiltonians that show that this
bound is tight have the property that
their Optimum is a gaussian state
so like it seems this is not we don't
know theorems along this line but it
seems like if you're close to this bound
then maybe actually gaussian states do
do well for you
so that's not known
um yeah like I think we're gonna hear
about Quantum Mexico today and I
literally don't know what happens if you
just like put Quantum Mexico out into
this format as a degree like a very
special kind of degree four
polynomial and then maybe apply like so
is rounding algorithm to it what happens
I don't know like gaussian States like
include product States but like they're
it's a bigger class so maybe something
good could happen
and
um well let me just advertise this paper
by Matt Hastings uh probably out of time
but um
he has some very interesting questions
about like how much does SOS know about
perturbation Theory which is like the
situation where like you have like a
simple hamiltonian and you know it's
Optimum but then you add in epsilon
times like a complicated hamiltonian
you know there's a lot of sophisticated
perturbation Theory using linear algebra
about like how that changes the optimum
value and you can understand maybe SOS
can model that perturbation Theory
or like I think this is a funny question
like is there a perturbation theory for
SOS like if you have an SOS style bound
if you know what this stuff means on
like a simple hamiltonian and then you
slightly perturb the hamiltonian
can you perturb the SOS certificate for
it and get like a comparable bound
I don't know
okay I'll stop there thanks
[Applause]
for you know what kinds of things
yeah I'm not expert in this but let me
try to say a little bit more precisely
what is meant
uh in this paper like he considers like
some basic hamiltonians like quadratic
hamiltonians in in the anti-competing
setting and the spin setting and also in
this continuous setting with like this
funny setting with them
a position of momentum operators
and you'll take like a degree two things
which you understand well and add like
Epsilon times a degree four thing
and I guess like in physics it's really
in linear algebra but like in physicists
like study this like you know by like
actually thinking about the matrices and
thinking about what happens when you
like take a matrix whose eigenvectors
and all good values you know well and
you perturb the Matrix a little bit how
do the eigenvalues change
there's like these three different ways
of like doing perturbation theory that
are named after like pairs or triples of
physicists which I don't know and they
understand they can tell you like what
happens up to first order and even
second order in any order
and um you know math paper is asking
like well you know perturbation Theory
tells you like it changes by at most
Epsilon times this expression does SOS
know that like can you show that like
the sum of squares method can also prove
like that's an upper bound up to first
order
and he really just does it by like kind
of the
first like grungy like thing where
you're just like I know what the answer
is I'm going to try to express it as a
sum of squares and sometimes he's able
to do it and sometimes he's like I don't
know how to do it
um but I don't maybe this is like a
wacky idea but like you know if SOS
understands the simple hamiltonian you
express like the hamiltonian minus the
maximum energy whatever as a sum of
squares and then you perturb the
hamiltonian
is there a way to like perturb the sum
of squares representation that would
like give you a Bound for the new
hamiltonian
uh I don't know but I think this is like
um maybe
it's like I don't know anything about
physics so I'm like uh what kinds of
hamiltonians do people actually care
about they're like actually motivated by
physics and like this is I guess
something that people care about a lot
like you have like a simple hamiltonian
and then like yeah you perturb it by
like a Epsilon times a more complicated
one
yep he said the degree for
anti-committing cases in some sense a
bit more powerful than I mean I
understand that it contains both of them
but in one sense can it be more
than say oh just in like the strictly I
just met a strictly formal sense that
like literally like you can simulate the
degree to local hamiltonian case with
degree four anti-commuting case
that's it but plus there are some I mean
you can also express some degree four
stuff that is not in this setting so
just like strictly at this formal level
that's all I meant by it
but it's not a wave
of quantifying to find that it's
strictly known Posse
well I guess like you can like if you're
interested in modeling fermionic
problems then you can like with you know
like only like local interactions you
can do it with like low degree uh
polynomials and anti-commuting case but
I think you cannot do it except with
like you know High degree like
proportional to n polynomials in the
the the like the policy spin model
and water
um
oh great question uh
um maybe yeah so this race is like
another excellent uh point which is like
another Avenue for like studying like
hamiltonians which is really interesting
is like thinking about like the graph
theoretic structure of like this I mean
you can write like a for uniform
hypergraph or if you have like a degree
two expression like the bipartite case
where like you have like two batches of
Kai's and Chi primes and every term
involves one Chi and one Chi Prime
uh I think it's like both physically
motivated and like a lot of the theory
changes maybe you get like better
approximation algorithms in this case as
well worth studying
um there are some results now actually
yeah about
yeah there might be I don't know
specific such results I think it's quite
possible because like this Bound for
example
um is based on like the Lobos
understanding the Lobos data function of
a graph so I think like if you get graph
theoretic considerations of like your
hamiltonian into play yeah definitely
things could change
um I guess like maybe okay not
necessarily the fully anti-commuting
setup but like just in the general I
know Quantum CSP setup
I think the the apartheid case is I
think often are always maybe for games
like considered more natural than the
like unipar type case so this is
definitely a good area to study
and maybe you should check out sales
paper you might consider it
okay thanks for your attention
[Applause]